from Microsoft extras organizers for
inviting me this is joint work with
Tegan wrong gay sham Kaka day and Mike
Jordan
you all know that non-convex
optimization arises all over the place
in machine learning especially
applications include matrix
factorization tensor decomposition
neural networks and so on right and the
workhorse for solving non convex
optimization problems in practice these
days he is gradient descent or gradient
descent based algorithms and given an
initial point x0 and the step size ETA
what gradient descent does is update the
point XT to be XT minus the step size
times the gradient at X for the class of
smooth functions where smoothness
essentially means that the gradient does
not change too fast or the Hessian is
upper bounded by a quantity L it is well
known that gradient descent converges
two points with gradient where the
gradient value is close to zero more
quantitatively after roughly 1 over
epsilon square iterations gradient
descent converges to a point where the
gradient value is less than Epsilon ok
here L is the smoothness parameter f of
X 0 is the initial function value and F
star is the global optimum and points
where the gradient II is smaller than
epsilon are called Epsilon first-order
stationary points so all this says is
that gradient descent converges to
first-order stationary points at this
particular rate first-order stationary
points can actually be of two types
either they can be local minima or they
can be saddle points even though
gradient descent can converge to either
of these two kinds of points they behave
quite differently in problems in
practice for instance in many
applications which come from matrix
factorization for instance local minima
are actually quite good
while Seidel points are not at all good
what I mean by that is that either local
minima have a value which is essentially
the same as the global minima or local
minima have values which are which is
very close to that of the global minima
on the other hand if you look at saddle
points in many of these problems and in
many other problems as well they can be
quite poor in terms of function value
compared to the global optimum and there
can be many more saddle points in
ambient space so the bottom line is that
local minima are much more desirable for
an algorithm to converge to than Seidel
points points is worse they although
convenient I can construct some on local
minimum worse than settle points yeah so
that's definitely possible all I'm
saying here is that at least there are
there have been several applications in
particular from coming from matrix
factorization where this is the case I'm
not saying that this is the case always
in these problems there are I mean
theoretically it has been proven that
local minima are satisfied these good
properties whereas there can be saddle
points which are bad in particular in
these problems theoretical yeah so the
bottom line is that local minima are
much more desirable to converge to as
compared to saddle points and it is also
the case that gradient descent can
indeed converge to saddle points and not
local minima so a natural question to
ask is if it is possible to make
gradient descent escape saddle points
and only converge to local minima right
in a work couple of years ago by gate
all it turns out that they show that by
adding by injecting noise in the
gradient descent updates by perturbing
the gradient descent updates by a little
bit of noise it turns out that you can a
gradient descent actually escapes idle
points and the but the result that the
show requires at least polynomial in D
number of iterations for escaping saddle
points so gradient descent may come
close to a saddle point and then you
inject noise and then after polynomial
in D iterations it actually escapes the
saddle point and go somewhere else so
the question we ask is if it is indeed
possible to do this more efficiently
without this Polly of D dependence okay
this question clear
so before I talk about results let me
introduce the notation notion of
second-order stationary points and in
this talk we assume that the functions
that we consider are smooth and Haitian
Lipschitz so the smoothness assumption
we just saw earlier it basically says
that the gradient does not change too
fast or equivalently that the Hessian is
upper bounded by this quantity L Hessian
Lipchitz essentially says that the
hessian does not change too fast and
this essentially means that the third
derivative is upper bounded by row and a
point X he says said to be an epsilon
second-order stationary point if the
gradient is smaller than epsilon and the
smallest eigen value of the second
derivative of the Hessian at X is at
least minus square root of epsilon so
the difference between epsilon and
square root works and is all to make the
units agree it is nothing fundamental or
anything of that sort this turns out to
be the right scaling to look at and was
originally defined in the straw and
polyak in their paper so with this
notation notation our result says that
whatever gradient descent I'll explain
what part of gradient descent ease
whatever gradient descent converges to
epsilon second-order stationary points
in essentially 1 over epsilon square I
durations here the au twiddle hides some
log factors including a log factor in
the dimension and the point to note here
is that our result says that this
perturbed gradient descent converges to
second-order stationary points in
essentially the same time up to log
factors as gradient descent takes to
converge to first order of stationary
points ok and again l and f of X 0 F of
F star all these are exactly the same
terms that we had in gradient descent
convergence and the O twiddle only hides
from log factors so essentially the same
as gradient descent convergence
guarantee
so what is the part of gradient descent
algorithm the algorithm at high level is
just this it keeps doing gradient
descent and once in a while it adds some
perturbation that's basically the pseudo
code so it keeps doing this gradient
descent on step four and once in a while
whenever the perturbation condition
holds it adds the noise which is in step
three
so just gradient descent and once in a
while add noise and what is this
perturbation condition basically the
perturbation condition kicks in
when the current point the gradient at
the current point is small and we
haven't added noise for a while so in
terms of the algorithm execution it fall
it goes as follows in the beginning we
start greedy in this end the gradient at
the current point might be large so we
just keep doing gradient descent at some
point the gradient becomes small and
then this perturbation condition kicks
in so we add a little bit of noise in
the next iteration we see that we have
just added noise so we will not put up
again we let it continue great doing
gradient descent for a while till some
items and then redo this procedure
entirely again so that's the algorithm
so I mean I'm not presenting the details
because of shortage of time like you can
see that in the paper but I'll give you
a brief proof outline which it comes up
the problem parameters both the
smoothness and the Hessian Lipchitz
conditioners yeah
okay so let me give you yeah so when you
don't make any function progress that's
when you know you have converged so let
me give you a brief proof idea so first
we recall the definition of second-order
stationary point so it says that either
the gradient is so both the gradient is
small and the smallest eigen value of
the hessian is greater than or equal to
this minus square root of Epsilon okay
let's say we are not at a second-order
stationary point we want to show that
we'll get away from that point right
because we eventually want to converge
to a second-order stationary points we
don't want to be stuck near something
that's not a second-order stationary
point so in the first case right so if
it's not a second or a stationary point
there are two sub cases the first case
the gradient is large right if the
gradient is large we can use smoothness
and the step size choice to show that we
actually decrease the function value
okay and there is a different case which
is that the gradient is actually small
but then the Hessian has a small eigen
direction as well has a negative eigen
direction as well in this case XT is
actually very close to a saddle point
because the gradient is very small and
there is actually a descent direction
right and the question is how do we use
this descent direction to actually
escape from here and that's what I'll
briefly try to explain so let's say the
center of this ball is the saddle point
so we are considering this ball around
the saddle point and then let s be the
set of all points in this ball from
where if you do gradient descent without
any noise you don't escape from this set
so we define the set s to be all the
points in this ball such that if you do
gradient descent from there you will
essentially be stuck inside you cannot
escape from the ball okay now the key
technical result that we show is that
the volume of the set s is small now
think of how the part of gradient
descent works so we are somewhere in
this ball here and then we add a little
bit of noise and once we add noise the
probability that will fall in
set is very small because the volume of
this ball is small a volume of this side
is small so will will with high
probability will fall in s complement
and what is the definition of s
complement the set of points from where
gradient descent actually escapes so the
key part is how do we show that the
volume of this set is small so this is a
different view of the this is a cross
sectional view of the same thing so if
you look at it like a cross-sectional
kind of view so let's say we okay so the
what we show is that let's say you lies
in the set okay we want to show that the
volume of s is small so how do we show
that so let's say U is a point which
lies in this set from where gradient
descent does not escape now we add so W
consider the point W which is obtained
by adding the negative y direction
direction to u so U is a point which
does not escape W is a point which is
gotten by adding the negative eigen
direction to you what we show is that if
you does not escape W will escape so for
every point inside s there are lot of
other points inside this ball which
actually escape this essentially gives
us this volume small volume result so
that's the key technical there is no
real over counting because what we show
is that you have this entire line so for
every point here okay so you can
essentially divide this ball into all
lines right so what we can show is that
this line intersects the set in a very
small portion
the intuition is that okay so these are
separated only by the negative direction
negative eigen direction right so if you
does not escape so you can write the
gradient descent updated W as gradient
descent updated to you plus gradient
descent update that follow from this
difference you know that this difference
actually diverges because it's in the
negative eigen direction and you know
that this does not escape so you can
bond this so when you sum both of them W
actually escapes that's so so just to
recap we show that so we know that
gradient design converges to first order
stationary points this is a classical
result and in this work what we show is
that part of gradient descent actually
converges to second order stationary
points at essentially the same rate up
to log factors and the key idea here is
to understand the structure around
saddle points to see what is the volume
of the point from where gradient descent
escapes compared towards the volume of
the points where gradient descent does
not escape okay and what I said what the
way I motivated this was actually to
escape from saddle points and so far I
have only told you about how to converge
to second order stationary points and
this is what connects both of them in
particular if we if the if our function
satisfies something called the strict
Seidel property which says that every
saddle point has a negative eigen
direction strictly negative eigen
direction it turns out that all
second-order stationary points are local
minima and our result directly gives you
convergence to local minima for these
kind of functions and this kind of this
property for instances observe has been
proved in mini matrix factorization
problems and moreover if we have local
strong convexity near a particularly
local minimum we can actually get
geometric convergence you know instead
of this one or epsilon square once we
are in the neighborhood these are direct
corollaries once we have the convergence
to a second-order stationary points no
sir
so just to summarize gradient descent
and a little amount of randomness can
actually escape Seidel points with only
a poly logarithmic dependence on the
dimension and the key ingredient is
understanding the geometry around saddle
points and there are a bunch of very
interesting open directions that this
work also suggests the first one is if
this occasional randomness is even
necessary for instance in practice we
would just start with a random point and
then be like yeah we just start so there
is already a randomness in the initial
point and is that sufficient to actually
escape saddle point so that's something
we don't know and the second one is if
you look at the algorithms that are
being developed for neural networks
recently right so Adam or rmsprop all
these things they are trying to use
momentum methods for these non convex
problems but it is not at all known if
these momentum methods can actually
probably help in obtaining better
guarantees for non convex problems and
finally the most interesting versions of
these algorithms would be in the
stochastic case where which we can
actually apply to trained neural nets
and other machine learning problems with
that I stopped thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
and in Bali these days both of them so
in their case they were adding noise in
every iteration whereas here we only
added once in a while and the analysis
is also quite different from their paper
yeah the volume of the bad points are
smaller yeah how small exponentially
smaller dimension or just constant it's
just constant so yeah